how's it goin bruh I don't know why
could dancing it's so corny welcome back
to the why did you do that Mac Big Show
it's time to throw the kick the grand
back and teleport oh yes we are haven't
finished it yet
but it shouldn't be too difficult keep
the girl get the mixtape and give it no
no max oh listen okay show me your
underwear and I suck at this
alright take it and give it to old man
wheeler to do that anymore
alright I got it now we go in here we
grab [ __ ] it's really difficult when um
we just jump in oh that was it [ __ ]
alright so here anyway we see something
here what if we click on it was that it
No thank God oh well actually would be
nice what if you click on the island
what if we click on the clouds what if
we just stop playing this and Evan what
about this oh and then we throw the
snowball egg okay it's still exploded
but I haven't all I know I know we just
throw it at the bomb yes
that was bad that one actually made
sense it's amazing and every time I see
it
pics yeah Victor dance I hate how are
you doing this but I'm doing it anyway I
hate myself returning space finger yes
let's finish this chapter 1 let's go to
this desert chapter one run three blow
your mind we will save the day for
shovel I think God the music change I
don't know a little repetitive for my
taste
alright we're at a bar there's two
pregnant dudes and the lady let's go to
the lady kick the lady doesn't do
anything well we have a bucket and the
lady wants to [ __ ] hey girl you want a
bucket she didn't want the bucket
alright we're in that elevator that's
totally fine there's an old dude here
and the old dude wants to fire
extinguisher because no we give it to
this guy
here you go that did not save us
we're at the sub-array my [ __ ] yeah and
[ __ ]
okay I got this breath don't worry we'll
look at the we look at the fishes lovely
hey that fish is high today ah running
out of time painting steer the wheel
let's go to the left it's still explodes
all right what do we got here then it's
a bird with two moving boobies nope or
should he have gas alright man take this
now don't hit me and we explode
fantastic oh we're at the skyscraper and
there's this def skull spider of course
huh yes I totally meant to do that
oh my god I don't even know anymore
breasts I really really don't know hey
man how ya doin what are you talking
about there's a bum behind me let me
check you your wedding a frog as a hat
let me fix that it's my that's not gonna
help those make fix all right okay we
have coffee nope we don't have we have
espresso machine let's drink you so
random holy [ __ ] all right okay we press
the button the old man goes flying and
we still die okay I'll write that down
so I know in the future in case on and
this all right we'll look out we see
fishes and we explode good okay
[ __ ] I ever got everybody's really fast
commentating me let's put the wrench
there and then they'll kill us is pretty
horribly actually yeah it's gotta be
something about this def spider let's
put you there go that spider oh my god
that spider you did it you are awesome
death spider
oh I feel bad for young-soon amnesia now
like I feel like he doesn't get the
credit he didn't meet the [ __ ] ticks
and bomb
okay don't worry about it bro we will
take the bucket and we will fill it with
coffee and that's it that's all I got
yes good job that's totally what I would
have done in this scenario okay this
time we will change the elevator floor a
lot of times so naturally we will never
fall nevermind okay I got this we never
touched him so let's kick him in the
balls doesn't work take the bomb and
given dildo doesn't work doesn't work
all right
I thought I had this one let's take his
club route stop all right it's gotta be
something about this frog hat what does
it do it oh oh I get it okay and now
what is that gonna go again John bombed
over there that's right you better get
yes yeah that's how we solve things this
game is hilarious I
all right I sold one holy [ __ ] wait a
gold solution okay keep the ladies not
gonna work the man's not gonna work the
other man what about this espresso dude
what do you want
let me slit your throat did I search
this what'd I do
okay new plan take this and we open the
door and we throw it out and oh my god
JD JD oh man I know this game all right
and it's like the only but oh oh there's
a thing here yes that should solve
everything
I'm such an idiot all right can we go
out and get Heinen no there's nothing
here what that was that we just kick it
[ __ ] me how was I supposed to know that
all right
let's take the coffee no I really don't
know this one all right bucket and man
yes okay I did it
that's good submarine that looks like
something else we take this and we open
the window and throw it outside yes that
was but that one made sense you're
wearing a doctor now anyway
I'm terrible I'm terrible at bonus today
is all right okay all right big country
Iraq yeah there's something moving over
here any bite me and we still dying [ __ ]
I thought I would smoke the game there
but now obviously I wasn't there's no
logic involved anyway so alright there's
kids playing video games and we go and
take his bomb and we go to the zoo
look at the giraffe [ __ ] awesome
giant alright are you doing that sir
just passing by
cephalo the giraffe hey giraffe do you
want some drugs okay we're at an office
and we grab the plant and then we go we
pretend that we can't be seen a [ __ ] it
doesn't right
Oh let's go pass and then percent flirt
with the Barcelona there you go but of
course of course it works all right no
it didn't work
all right and we just go explodes inside
of the house of course where I didn't -
shift in one of these oh yeah okay doc I
arranged it for you you will solve this
know that for life from bad now all
right let's get the shotgun and shoot
the TV and he's probably gonna run out
crying or some [ __ ] like that
can I shoot it oh he shot the TV that
doesn't solve anything but he didn't
like the plan I thought I had that one
oh here's the bomb oh I got it I got it
I got it oh [ __ ] okay TV hey Tibbie
sorry I need to borrow this got a bomb
to say I didn't work I got a fire
extinguisher naturally I should put the
fire out that's that that's not how you
put the fire out why are you doing this
god damn you man all right duck to the
monster yes
yes it did Oh No that doesn't help
anyone [ __ ] all right I got a new plan
shotgun
note this loading fail run haha
it's still gonna blow up no that was oh
my god just let's calm down calm down
all right I know this one the pot
obviously fits this little thing so
let's just put it down there
yep that was easy that love when it
makes sense actually all right let's see
if we can get a bonus level on this one
okay new plan we take his hatch we just
we just take the fire no come on just go
to it that's right that totally makes
that really really come on dude
all right last one okay this is opening
yes thank you my quick cells so much
that is enough
aye aye do you remember that warning and
the beginning I starting to make sense
of that right now
but I got to do a dance and we've gotta
end this episode but like as you enjoy
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see you next episode
I know you just sit there and look
beautiful
alright okay and now that that is there
I need to put another portal uh-oh oh
this is gonna be cool looking okay you
ready for this oh my god are you ready
for this I guess I'm looking beautiful
okay